To recap, you made a new app called Festival
app. And when you created that app, the platform automatically
created an object to track Festivals. You added fields
to capture the start and end dates, and then you
created a record for a specific festival, which Samantha
and Andy called Cloudstock. Objects, fields, records. These terms might
still be a little unfamiliar to you. If that's confusing,
let's step back for a moment and relate this model
to something you're probably already comfortable with, spreadsheets.
If you were to track this same information with
a simple spreadsheet, it might look something like this.
You'd create a new spreadsheet called Festivals. And you'd
add a column for Festival Name, Start Date, and
Date. Then you'd add Cloudstock as a row under
those headers and complete the dates. You can add
many different festivals as new rows on that spreadsheet.
Now this is starting to make sense. Based on this analogy, how do these
terms objects, fields, and records correspond to
tables, columns, and rows on a spreadsheet?